all right and we are live Soulcalibur
action if you Choice Award and I already
know who Lord Sam is going Nick this is
the moment he's been waiting for
the waltz until this debris also not
never look at the character usage rate
on the role here classic nightmare y'all
[Music]
Hey look stunning
[Music]
I like that force Bush okay Sam he's
quick with them he's quick with the
vertical slashes they're all the lotuses
[Music]
you gotta leave that you gotta leave
that grab alone
it back to them smashes throw old on
here what's going on here what's
happening
oh that looks crazy I don't know what he
did I said I love that y'all don't know
what y'all doing but this is fantastic
the way it looks know what they're sayin
sayin it's way down
[Laughter]
name is so soft he's so tough he's got
the tough slashes man good game man good
game
so caliber looking beginning back you
don't want another round you good he's
good he's good he's got it he's got a
little taste of the roll how did it feel
though I didn't feel what's going on
down here just so you know big fan day
one purchase all right